merci pour votre accueil de la vidéo de
françois fillon je vous avoue qu'elle
est un peu sorti dans la précipitation
vu le contexte il y avait autour de lui
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du
programme pour les présidentielles d'un
autre candidat jean-luc mélenchon son
objectif est plutôt claire engager la
france dans une transition vers une
société plus douce et plus égalitaire
dans ses rapports sociaux et pour lui il
ya clairement une urgence d urgence même
démocratie pour mélenchon l'urgence
démocratique c'est de rendre le pouvoir
aux citoyens comment en convoquant une
assemblée constituante qui exclura de
ses membres les parlementaires de la
vème république et qui aura pour but de
rédiger la nouvelle constitution celle
de la sixième république qui sera
ensuite validé par référendum
ensuite l'idée de réintégrer
l'intervention populaire dans le
quotidien la démocratie en rendant le
vote obligatoire dès 16 ans en tenant
compte du vote blanc comme un suffrage
exprimé ou en généralisant l'utilisation
du référendum
son objectif c'est de balayer le gâchis
politique d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire
quand le pouvoir appartient à un groupe
minoritaire
et pour ça il propose entre autres de
rendre les corrompus inéligible à vie et
de lutter contre le lobby assez logique
de société plus égalitaire il souhaite
mettre fin au pillage économique de la
nation et protéger l'intérêt général de
l'oligarchie
il va entre autres créé mission
parlementaire spéciale pour voir le
bilan de toutes les privatisations et
faveurs fiscales décidées depuis trois
décennies et rendre effectif le droit de
réquisition inverse de la privatisation
des entreprises d'intérêt général par
l'état comme edf par exemple concernant
les salariés
il propose d' empêcher les licenciements
économiques collectifs quand
l'entreprise va bien il le fait en
interdisant le versement de dividendes
dans les entreprises qui ont recours aux
licenciements économiques et propose
aussi une sixième semaine de congés
payés une application stricte des 35
heures dans le privé la retraite à 60
ans et une augmentation du smic selon
lui il faut travailler moins pour
travailler tous
concernant le patronat il envisage de
fixer un salaire maximum autorisé pour
limiter l'écart 2 1 à 20 entre le
salaire le plus bas le salaire le plus
haut il veut interdire les stock options
ou d'autres avantages comme les
parachutes dorés ou trouver l'argent
pour financer tout ça la première étape
c'est de refuser le chantage à la dette
publique en mettant en place un audit
citoyen pour en déterminer la part
illégitime et en préparer un
réaménagement négocié la seconde c'est
la mise en place d'une véritable
révolution fiscale rendre l'impôt plus
progressif avec un barème à quatorze
tranches contre 5 aujourd'hui
pour que chacun paie selon ses revenus
l'instauration d'un revenu maximum
autorisé
100 % d'impôt de la 400000 euros annuels
une réévaluation des niches fiscales
la refonte de l'impôt sur les sociétés
pour rétablir l'égalité entre pme et
grands groupes et le renforcement de
l'aide sociale se battant contre
l'inégalité mélenchon se prononce contre
toutes les discriminations de genre de
couleur d'handicap de tous il souhaite
abolir le patriarcat en renforçant la
loi et les moyens contre les violences
faites aux femmes en renforçant le rôle
d'éducation du planning familial en
adoptant une loi de lutte contre le
sexisme en abolissant la prostitution et
surtout en imposant l'égalité des
conditions entre hommes et femmes
cependant même s'il est pour la
procréation médicalement assistée pour
toutes les femmes et refuse la gpa
gestation pour autrui sur la question la
laïcité il souhaite garantir la liberté
de conscience et l'égalité de toutes les
options spirituelles devant la loi tout
en combattant tous les communautarismes
et l' usage politique des religions il
propose d'ailleurs de refuser de
rencontrer les pays qui imposerait aux
ministres femmes détenues contraire à la
dignité républicaine il propose aussi
l'éradication pure et simple de la
pauvreté par des mesures instaurant la
gratuité de quantités d'eau de gaz et
d'électricité indispensable à une vie
digne ou la mise en place d'un plan 0
sans abri pour apporter accompagnement
et logement d'urgence à ces derniers
écologie on l'a dit mélenchon va vers
une transition vers une société plus
douce et pour lui ça implique une
transition écologique et propose donc
d'engager un plan de relance de
l'activité et de l'emploi au service de
la transition écologique en injectant
100 milliards d'euros dans l'économie
pour des investissements écologiquement
et socialement utiles il veut aussi une
sortie complète du nucléaire en
impliquant les personnes qui travaillent
dans les opérations de démantèlement
il vise aussi 100% d'énergies
renouvelables d'ici à 2050 globalement
l'idée qui persiste dans son programme
c'est de faire évoluer notre façon de
consommer transformant notre pays en
france zéro déchet combattants
l'obsolescence programmée et soutenant
les filières et les initiatives de
gestion des déchets il souhaite aussi
mettre en place une agriculture paysanne
refusant les ogm et bannissant les
pesticides nuisibles pour protéger nos
écosystèmes 10 blu massy l'urgence
démocratique elle passe aussi selon
mélenchon par l'europe
selon lui elle est décomposé et l
attaque la démocratie elle oppose entre
les salariés des pays membres en
refusant toute harmonisation sociale et
fiscale
il est nécessaire pour la france de
reconquérir son indépendance et cette
europe là soit on la change plan
soit on la quitte plan b il veut aussi
sortir de l'otan pour sortir de l'
influence américaine et se recentrer sur
notre rôle à l'onu pour lui notre pays
et universaliste et doit se recentrer
sur sa coopération avec les pays
émergents et tout particulièrement
l'afrique
donc voilà engager la france dans une
transition vers une société plus douce
et plus égalitaire dans ses rapports
sociaux à travers plusieurs urgence
démocratique économique sociale
écologique et diplomatique sur le
fondement du programme de jean luc
mélenchon et j'espère qu'il est plus
claire maintenant je mets la description
les sources par son programme complet
pour que vous puissiez aller plus loin
par vous même et on se retrouve très
vite pour le prochain candidat vous
invite également très fortement à les
voir la chaîne de la mine ugo décrypte
qui habitués au format de type 5 minutes
pour décrypter un programme c'est
quelque chose qui fait pour tous les
candidats de la présidentielle et contre
est forcément différemment
donc ça peut être très enrichissant pour
vous il a aussi une série d'interviews
augmentée qui permettent d'aller plus
loin dans le programme des candidats
donc je vous invite à y aller je vous
mets le lien de sa chaîne en
descriptions j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu merci à tous les types
heures qui soutiennent financièrement le
projet on se revoit bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo love peace